under the streets of Vancouver at the
University of British Columbia there are
pneumatic tubes two and a half
kilometers long that use air pressure to
transport slightly radioactive stuff
underground from a particle accelerator
to a hospital the tubes are called the
rabbit line and the only sign of them
from the surface is a few manholes and
some little studs in the ground to Mark
the path most of the students and staff
here at UBC have no idea that a few
times every day underneath their feet
capsules with radioactive stuff speed
buy at up to 100 kilometers an hour so
we're going to start at the particle
accelerator here and explain how how the
stuff made and how it's sent and then at
the receiving end at the hospital we're
going to explain why this is a GMP Lab
at once and here we use medical Isotopes
and make tweezers for Imaging and
therapy so in accelerators we have
cyclotron so cyclotron we inject H minus
so negative charges hydrogen and spin it
around they get really really fast carry
a lot of energy and we extract that H
minus to proton and then we use proton
beam to the Target once they hit Target
or produce radioactive isotopes and once
we have the Isotopes they'll be
transferred here and here our chemists
will do their magic so they combine with
some injectable liquid mostly saline the
ones processed in this lab are
short-lived Isotopes two particular one
is the carbon 11 and the carbon 11 only
have 20 minutes Half-Life our chemist is
doing a very fast job and then they send
this to the rapid line to UBC hospital
and inject to patients the long-lived
Isotopes will produce probably nanogram
range the short level one is even
smaller than that amount that's all you
need so particle accelerator upstairs
makes the Isotopes Chemists in the clean
room turn them into a liquid the team in
this room put that vial inside a rabbit
a capsule and into that tube there's one
already loaded close it up push the
right buttons and 100 PSI of air
pressure accelerate it to a top speed of
100 kilometers an hour now I am not
allowed to send a camera down the line
it's really carefully calibrated you
don't take risks like that with Medical
Treatments plus it's pitch black at also
percent of light as well but I did ask
if I could push the button it's just the
big one marked send right okay
[Music]
surprisingly loud
because we're sending it over
underground the soil under the road was
so as a very good shielding also because
the amount we send is very very little
we are sending a dough set actually safe
to injecting a human in inside the body
so for the public there's no Hazard if
we drive up the streets it will take
about 10-15 minutes but if we shoot
through the rapid line it only takes a
little bit over two minutes and it's
more reliable and we don't need to stop
at stop sign about two and a half
minutes later the capsule arrives here
at the university hospital but that does
raise the question when the capsule is
going that fast how does it stop in the
right place every time when a close to
the end about 10 meters to the end there
is a vent so you will lose the pressure
from the compressed air and also the
front the air is compressed so it serves
as a buffer to slow down the rabbit as
well and that which allows the rabbit to
drop simply at the hospital
that isn't the same capsule it's a 10
minute drive away the rabbit line is
incredibly fast which leaves the big
question why well what's being sent are
radio Pharmacy cuticles slightly
radioactive stuff that here is meant for
research in medicine obviously I'm not
filming any research subjects here but
the staff let me know what sort of thing
this can be used for when this
radioactive substance decays it emits
gamma rays which we detect
in doing that we can then reconstruct
the image you can actually see how the
brain works without really getting into
the brain very very important picture
that you couldn't get otherwise by
definition they cannot have any
pharmacological effect on the body
if it were to inject anything that
changes the system we're not looking at
the system we're looking at the system
as modified Jim Parkinson's Disease by
the time you have clinical symptoms the
brain is already very very damaged
that's why we observe populations at
risk and then of course we've done some
studies in Psychiatry mood disorders in
dementia addiction the discovery that
there is a neurochemical placebo effect
a neurotransmitter release when people
were expecting some benefit of a drug
even when a drug was not given it turns
out around the world quite a few
hospitals have their own particle
accelerators maybe for diagnosis maybe
for treatment maybe like here for
research although they do normally use a
slightly less dramatic way of
transporting the results which left me
with two questions no one could answer
the first which is why it's called a
rabbit line apparently no one here knows
but the second one was how do they get
the rabbits back to the start drive it
we pick it up or they send it over the
old school